the council's are the main legislative
bodies of the European Union it is kind
of the house of 27 member states
it's where ministers meets for each
country the Council of Ministers meeting
various formations and in each case the
ministers that are responsible for
specific feats take part and when
compromise is made on the basis of a
proposition from the Commission then we
will negotiate with the European
Parliament our role my role as president
of the council it's more of a
facilitator a mediator our aim is to
reach consensus it is a challenge you're
chairing a meeting in another language
and some of the issues that we are
debating of a very complex nature the
most difficult part is what what is
required before you sit at the table so
good preparation is essential you have a
personal contract with each member of
the council knowing the background of
each one's position is important so you
get to know the wise and the words
I think it's very important that you can
hear what other people say that that you
really listen not just you know given
the floor and say thank you but that you
really listen understanding the other's
position is a key element in reaching
decisions on a European level there's
been a lot of fuss and worry and debate
about Europe in general but Europe is
also working we can take decisions we
can throw light of the way that some
financial products are traded we can
make sure that we handle foreign policy
situation we can be in in farming and
agriculture and environment and climate
energy efficiency we're taking decision
this will be better for the citizens in
the future because it's important that
the union work no matter the crisis no
matter the debates about how Europe
listen in in the global standing